in a landmark case in new york a jury  has found teva pharmaceuticals  responsible for contributing to the  state's opioid crisis teva told cbs news  it is preparing an appeal and asking for  a mistrial claiming the plaintiffs  presented no causal relationship between  teva's conduct including its marketing  and any harm to the public in the state  new york's attorney general called the  verdict significant for every family and  community torn apart by opioids she said  a jury has found an opioid manufacturer  responsible for the death and  destruction they inflicted on the  american people teva will now face  another trial to determine damages in  the case